according to a national retail
Federation survey 70 percent of Shoppers
are planning to shop this week after
Christmas the organization saying it's
all to take advantage of holiday sales
and promotions Mary Jane beliesa is live
at the Boulevard Mall so Mary Jane how
busy is it there
David and Denise it's quite busy when we
got here this morning the parking lot
was full and even right now this
afternoon we got here about 30 minutes
ago the parking lot is still full so
plenty of shoppers out here and those we
spoke with say they're excited to see
what deals they could find
the day after Christmas is a busy one
for many retailers as Shoppers are
looking to snag some deals and discount
items pop Shack was doing 15 off and I
had some top Shack dollars that were
going to expire on the 31st so I figured
I'd come and get a good deal Shopper
Matthew Hoffman headed straight for pop
Shack and came out with the very thing
he wanted I got a prayer action figure
I'm a big Predator fan
he lights up
and he's big and ugly and massive and
nasty
so and it's my favorite thing several
stores down Shopper Rod Nisha Olden
didn't mind standing in line to get into
Bath and Body Works we came for the Bath
and Body Works Deals they have 75 off
and 50 off and it's the only deal that
they have for the rest of the year it's
become a tradition to shop after
Christmas to find gifts for the whole
family without breaking the bank it was
amazing we saved a lot of money I think
we saved about 89 today Elizabeth and
Anna Chacon also checking for deals we
just decided to go shopping before yeah
just last minute just to see what they
had Elizabeth says she saw many people
shopping around and also returning gifts
but says customers need to be aware they
might not always get cash back instead
of doing cash it's just like
um
our story credit so you just exchange
yeah yeah like instead of getting like
your money back you have to get
something else in the store and at some
stores you might not get anything at all
I'll sell their final yeah so like you
have to be for sure if you want to buy
it or that's like me I just do gift
cards can't go wrong with a gift card
and other sales I saw include discount
offers on cell phone mobile lines even
discounts on pet items anywhere from
bedding and even home furniture Goods
really something for everyone here
reporting live Mary Jane valleza 8 news
now and at some stores some of these
Christmas deals are extended until New
Year's so malls across the valley might
see plenty of foot traffic heading into
the new year